其他人:给你一拳
Others: Give you a punch
Jake:走走走走走走
Jake: Go, go, go, go, go
Jake:就是这个
Jake: That's it
Jake:哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: Hahaha, idiot
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 然后有的时候还打
Shure: And sometimes it hits
Jake:你要穿
Jake: You have to wear
Shure: 完啊跑对
Shure: Finish, run correctly
Jake:你要穿模
Jake: You have to phase through
Jake:你会穿模吗
Jake: Can you phase through?
Shure: 我这穿模有点费劲
Shure: Phasing through is a bit hard for me
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
其他人:我操这是他妈的这个沙雕
Others: Damn, this idiot
其他人:抖音上的短视频居然出现我眼前
Others: The short video on TikTok appeared in front of me
Lucia:刚应该给你俩录一下的
Lucia: Should have recorded you two just now
其他人:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:都录了录着了录着了
Jake: It's all recorded, recording
Jake:都有我第一视角就沙雕
Jake: I got the first-person view, just an idiot
Lucia:也行我好
Lucia: That's fine, I'm good
其他人:哈哈我好奇我们到时候音频要喘吗
Others: Haha, I'm curious if we'll have to transmit the audio later
Jake:传啊这个都传
Jake: Transmit, everything transmits
其他人:我总感觉这音频要自己
Others: I always feel like the audio will
其他人:这音频到时数据一清洗
Others: When the data is cleaned
其他人:全洗完了
Others: All cleaned up
其他人:哈哈哈残缺不全
Others: Hahaha, incomplete
Shure: 还有什么比较适合走啊
Shure: What else is suitable for walking?
Shure: 这个也适合
Shure: This is also suitable
Katrina: 有点像跳popping的
Katrina: Looks a bit like popping dance
Katrina: 哈哈什么都精通啊就说
Katrina: Haha, you're good at everything
Katrina: 真假真牛
Katrina: Really, truly amazing
Jake:缺点墨镜这倒是
Jake: Just need some sunglasses, though
Tasha: 没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: （歌词）乍风倦我日夜想万众凝望悲愤愤怒
Shure: (lyrics) The sudden wind tires me, thinking day and night, the crowd stares in anger and resentment.
Tasha: 不行嗯
Tasha: No, it won't work.
Jake:这些车牌号都得干掉
Jake: All these license plates need to be removed.
Jake:我靠哈哈好烦呐
Jake: Oh man, haha, so annoying.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:就要干掉嘛
Jake: They need to be removed.
其他人：我昨天还看季风带在朋友圈发
Others: I saw a post about Monsoon on my WeChat moments yesterday.
其他人：他用那个英特VL
Others: He used that Intel VL.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：然后两辆车
Others: And two cars.
其他人：一辆宝马一辆奔驰
Others: A BMW and a Mercedes.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：然后那个标就是那种巨小的那种
Others: And the logo was so tiny.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：然后他就问英特VL
Others: Then he asked Intel VL.
其他人：说这辆这个宝马车车牌号多少
Others: What’s the license plate number of this BMW?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：他会卧槽OK
Others: He was like "Whoa, okay."
Jake:OK
Jake: Okay.
其他人：非常的厉害
Others: So impressive.
Shure: 我是不是应该穿个膜什么
Shure: Should I wear a mask or something?
其他人：你这时候应该往这走
Others: You should move this way now.
其他人：就就卡在这个里
Others: Just get stuck in here.
其他人：卡在这个里
Others: Get stuck in here.
其他人：卡在这卡
Others: Get stuck here.
Jake:你卡在两侧中间对
Jake: You get stuck in the middle of both sides, yeah.
其他人： 卡进去卡在路的中间
Others: Get stuck in the middle of the road.
Shure: 或者NF直接进入载具吧我还是
Shure: Or should NF just get into the vehicle, I guess.
其他人：你可以录我一段
Others: Can you record a bit for me?
Jake:谢丽哈哈
Jake: Shelly, haha.
Jake:谢丽哈哈哈哈哈哈一路抖音吗
Jake: Shelly, hahaha, are you recording this for Douyin all the way?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 下去吧你
Shure: Get down, you.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: （歌词）他们朝我扔泥巴
Shure: (lyrics) They threw mud at me
Shure: （歌词）我拿泥巴种荷花
Shure: (lyrics) I used the mud to plant lotus flowers
Lucia:从未觉得这么平凡的一条路
Lucia: Never thought such an ordinary road
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah
Lucia:能有这么多的危险
Lucia: Could be so dangerous
Shure: 平凡的路这平凡吗
Shure: An ordinary road, is this ordinary?
Lucia:平凡吗
Lucia: Ordinary?
Shure: 我曾经跨过山和大海
Shure: I once crossed mountains and seas
Lucia:也走过人山人海
Lucia: And walked through crowds of people
Shure: 我曾经拥有过的一切
Shure: I once had everything
Lucia:忘了哈哈哈
Lucia: And forgot it, hahaha
Shure: （歌词） 我曾经像你像他像那野草野花
Shure: (lyrics) I once was like you, like him, like the wild grass and flowers
Shure: 这个口音一定要模仿到位
Shure: This accent must be imitated perfectly
Shure: 直到平凡
Shure: Until ordinary
Shure: 朴树
Shure: Pu Shu
Lucia:我ICOD储存空间已满
Lucia: My ICOD storage is full
Jake:回头率不低啊
Jake: Turning heads, huh?
Shure: happy
Shure: Happy
Shure: birthday
Shure: Birthday
Jake:走我们去我们去给他们祝贺一下
Jake: Let's go, let's go congratulate them
Shure: to you
Shure: To you
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈你这什么社交恐怖分子吗
Lucia: Hahaha, are you some kind of social terrorist?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: happy birthday to you
Shure: Happy birthday to you
Jake:哈哈哈这几个像伪装起来
Jake: Hahaha, they look disguised
Shure: happy birthday to you
Shure: Happy birthday to you
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha
Shure: 今天你生日
Shure: It's your birthday today
Shure: 送给你祝福
Shure: Sending you blessings
Shure: 哒哒
Shure: Da da
其他人:（歌词）哒哒哒我们相亲又相爱
Others: (lyrics) Da da da, we love each other
Shure: （歌词）哒幸福美满
Shure: (lyrics) Da, happiness and bliss
Shure: （歌词）跟所有的烦恼说拜拜
Shure: (lyrics) Say goodbye to all troubles
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈这活动不适合爱一人参加
Katrina: Hahaha, this event isn't suitable for someone who loves solitude
Shure: 说嗨嗨
Shure: Say hi
Jake:我错了哈哈哈哈
Jake: I was wrong, hahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈啊哈哈过了吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is it over?
Shure: 喂喂喂哈哈
Shure: Hey hey hey haha
Jake:没有没有他错了
Jake: No no, he got it wrong.
Jake:对了对了对了哈哈
Jake: That's right, that's right, haha.
Lucia:行大家都是社交恐怖分子是吧
Lucia: So, we're all social terrorists, right?
其他人：我其实是哀人
Others: Actually, I'm a sad person.
Jake:对我我我们一排爱人
Jake: Yeah, we are a row of lovers.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:哈哈你觉得我信吗哈哈
Lucia: Haha, do you think I believe that? Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:月亮
Jake: The moon.
Shure: （歌词）里呀嘛更儿里呀
Shure: (Lyrics) Liyama Geng'er Liya
Shure: （歌词）月牙照花台
Shure: (Lyrics) The crescent moon shines on the flower terrace
Jake:耶唱歌呢
Jake: Hey, singing!
Shure: 一场又是一场
Shure: One after another.
Jake:对今儿周末应该挺多是闲人
Jake: Yeah, it's the weekend, so there should be a lot of free people.
Shure: 抛在脑后
Shure: Put it behind me.
Katrina: 你为啥去安河桥啊
Katrina: Why did you go to Anhe Bridge?
Shure: （歌词）早知如此何必开始
Shure: (Lyrics) If I had known, why start
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 我怕你们不接我了哈哈哈
Shure: I'm afraid you guys won't pick me up, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈那问题也不大是不是
Jake: Hahaha, it's not a big deal, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：你是想让我接还是不想让我们接
Others: Do you want me to pick you up or not?
Lucia:这么大个人了
Lucia: Such a big person.
Lucia:反正不会丢
Lucia: You won't get lost anyway.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Shure: 怕我怕我怕我怕我的屁股不保
Shure: I'm scared, I'm scared my butt won't be safe.
其他人：今天晚上干什么
Others: What are we doing tonight?
Shure: 怕什么
Shure: Afraid of what?
Shure: 你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 谢郡主
Shure: Thanks, princess.
Shure: 你要你要你要你要你要你要揪我屁股
Shure: You want, you want, you want to grab my butt.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:记一下记一下记一下记一下记一下
Jake: Write it down, write it down, write it down.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈秀秀这单你自己解
Jake: Haha, Shure, you handle this one yourself.
Katrina: 记哈哈哈
Katrina: Write it down, haha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：我们要剪的就是全全额保留了
Others: We need to keep the full version.
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
其他人:你们要剪就都保留走
Others: If you want to keep it, keep everything.
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Shure: 到时候就是语音识别问题这一段
Shure: This part will be about speech recognition issues.
其他人:这一段你说呗
Others: You can say this part.
Shure: 你说呗
Shure: You can say it.
Jake:他收音挺好的
Jake: It records quite well.
Jake:呵呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yes.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 我靠那我
Shure: Oh wow, then I...
Jake:因为他就在你脸上了
Jake: Because it's right in front of your face.
其他人：你 18:50亿修说几只
Others: 18:50 billion, Shure said a few.
其他人：19点就是修说逆天哈哈哈
Others: At 19:00, Shure said it was incredible, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:12:21危险言论
Others: 12:21 dangerous speech.
Jake:哈哈哈哈危险言论
Jake: Hahaha, dangerous speech.
Lucia:我有没有说过什么
Lucia: Did I say anything...
Lucia:哈哈不适合的我忘记了
Lucia: Haha, inappropriate? I forgot.
Jake:不管不管
Jake: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Jake:到时候看吧
Jake: We'll see later.
Shure: 慢慢削吧你们就
Shure: Just slowly edit it.
Jake:对慢慢削吧
Jake: Yes, slowly edit it.
Shure: 我只负责生产数据
Shure: I only produce data.
Shure: 不负责处理数据
Shure: I don't handle data.
Tasha: 哇真的吗
Tasha: Wow, really?
Shure: 提上裤子警报
Shure: Pull up your pants alarm.
Shure: 哈哈哈没事没事
Shure: Hahaha, it's nothing.
Jake:擅长生产无用数据哈哈哈
Jake: You're good at producing useless data, hahaha.
Alice:露西亚在吗
Alice: Is Lucia here?
Jake:又有小车
Jake: There's another car.
Shure: use protection
Shure: Use protection.
Jake:准备FFF FF
Jake: Get ready, FFF, FF.
Shure: not use protection
Shure: Not use protection.
其他人：是那个姐姐那个姐姐
Others: It's that sister, that sister.
Jake:先拿一下站嘴边
Jake: Hold it near your mouth first.
Jake:然后会停
Jake: Then it will stop.
Jake:就是我们的姐姐
Jake: It's our sister.
Jake:哈喽这是
Jake: Hello, this is...
Jake:对对就是送快递的姐姐
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it's the delivery lady.
Shure: 这姐不会看的
Shure: She won't see it.
Shure: 他直接会撞过去的
Shure: She'll just crash into it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 他每次坐车呼呼开着就玩手机
Shure: Every time she drives, she's always on her phone.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
其他人:你这个动作不对
Others: You're doing it wrong.
其他人：他带我说是两个手在玩手机
Others: He said he plays with his phone with both hands.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:你动作太保守了
Lucia: You're being too conservative.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure: 师傅捎一段吧
Shure: Master, give us a ride.
Shure: 咱们应该打车过去的
Shure: We should take a cab.
Shure: 打辆商务哈哈哈
Shure: Let's get a business car, haha.
Lucia:23456确实哈
Lucia: 23456, indeed.
Shure: 反正有经费
Shure: We have the budget anyway.
Shure: 晚上做什么梦
Shure: What did you dream about last night?
Jake:欢庆春节
Jake: Celebrating the Spring Festival.
Shure: 这两天睡得不踏实
Shure: I haven't been sleeping well these days.
Shure: 不踏实
Shure: Not well at all.
Shure: 你滚
Shure: Get lost.
Shure: 你妈要是躺我旁边我都得做噩梦
Shure: If your mom was lying next to me, I'd have nightmares.
其他人：昨天晚上睡觉动了吗
Others: Did you move while sleeping last night?
Jake:我不知道OK
Jake: I don't know, okay.
Shure: 你不你你不会
Shure: No, no, you wouldn't.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 真不知道
Shure: Really don't know.
Jake:哈哈哈我应该知道什么吧
Jake: Hahaha, should I know something about it?
Shure: 完了我应该知道什么吧
Shure: Oh no, should I know something about it?
其他人:因为我觉得我睡得很踏实啊
Others: Because I think I slept really well.
Shure: 啊我就是应该问健康
Shure: Ah, I should have asked about your health.
Shure: 摸摸自己的屁股疼吗哈哈哈
Shure: Check if your butt hurts, haha.
Jake:你再你再挤一条
Jake: Come on, squeeze out another one.
Jake:你再挤一条
Jake: Squeeze out another one.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 哎呀他得会这些东西
Shure: Oh man, he should know these things.
Jake:哈哈哈你能不能不让学术
Jake: Hahaha, can you stop being so academic?
Shure: 这些我是我们
Shure: This is us
Shure: 人之常情
Shure: It's human nature
Jake:这些做学术的人做这东西
Jake: These academic people do these things
Shure: 做学术的人就没有吃喝拉撒吗难道
Shure: Do academic people not eat, drink, and sleep?
Jake:有但是好像没有你说的这些东西
Jake: They do, but not like you said
Shure: 开玩笑那罗罗罗丽岛是吧
Shure: Just kidding, it's like Lolo Island, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈谁把修硕的嘴全删了
Katrina: Hahaha, who deleted all the academic stuff?
其他人:他妈的7.08-09全删完
Others: Damn it, everything from 7.08-09 is deleted
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Katrina: 把嘴巴捂住
Katrina: Cover your mouth
Shure: 就揭开他们丑陋的面纱
Shure: Just uncover their ugly veils
Shure: 不要一个个当
Shure: Don't act like
Lucia:一个个我都不想出现在这个画符里了
Lucia: I don't even want to be in this scene anymore
Shure: 反正我以后不搞学术
Shure: Anyway, I'm done with academia
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 我马上上班了哈哈哈
Shure: I'm starting work soon, haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Shure: 人家都是时间点
Shure: Others have fixed times
Shure: 我这时间段是吧
Shure: I have time slots, right?
Jake:唱点能播的
Jake: Sing something that can be broadcast
Jake:哈哈完了哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, it's over, hahaha
Shure: 能播的有啥的人
Shure: What's there to broadcast?
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing
Jake:曲库里面没有
Jake: There's nothing in the music library
Jake:不存在的
Jake: It doesn't exist
Shure: 确实你要
Shure: Indeed, if you
Shure: 说播点不能播
Shure: Want to play something unplayable
Shure: 我一下能给你唱10首
Shure: I can sing you 10 songs right away
其他人:那你先唱吧我给你接着唱
Others: Then you sing first, I'll follow
Shure: 别了然后咱们取快递
Shure: No, then we'll go pick up the package
Shure: 不行取快递的这个珍贵影像就没了
Shure: No way, this precious footage of picking up the package will be lost
其他人:你不仅要顶你一个人的眼镜
Others: You have to wear glasses for everyone
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Shure: 之后就开始删微信了
Shure: Then start deleting WeChat
Jake:再见了哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Goodbye, hahaha
Shure: 再见了家人们哈哈
Shure: Goodbye, everyone, haha
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 这什么地啊
Shure: What kind of place is this?
Shure: 这不会是一个
Shure: Could this be a...
Shure: 珐琅吧
Shure: ...cloisonné?
Lucia:工作室可能是的
Lucia: Might be a workshop.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:里面有人
Jake: There's someone inside.
Shure: 哟
Shure: Yo.
Shure: 可不是吗
Shure: Isn't there?
Shure: 居然有人
Shure: There's actually someone.
Jake:有好几个人
Jake: There are quite a few people.
Jake:呵嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:好这翻译的
Jake: Wow, this translation...
Lucia:牛啊
Lucia: Impressive!
Shure: 这翻译的
Shure: This translation...
Jake:我信不信达雅
Jake: Do I believe it or not?
Shure: 就是信不信达雅吧就说
Shure: Just whether you believe it or not.
Jake:这很难很难信
Jake: It's hard, really hard to believe.
Jake:很难不信达雅哈哈哈
Jake: Hard not to believe, haha.
Shure: 真的我这可以实时转意
Shure: Seriously, I can translate in real time.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright then.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:如意看见没
Jake: Did you see that?
Jake:AF OK哈哈哈哈
Jake: AF OK, hahaha.
Shure: if OK哈哈哈
Shure: If OK, hahaha.
Shure: if come
Shure: If come.
Shure: happy啊这个如意啊啊
Shure: Happy, this is good luck!
Jake:啊吉祥如意
Jake: Ah, auspicious and good luck.
其他人:follow your heart
Others: Follow your heart.
Lucia:是这边吧
Lucia: Is it this way?
其他人:我怎么感觉
Others: How do I feel...
其他人:都要走到那个什么卫生间了
Others: ...like we're heading to the bathroom?
Jake:就是那哦
Jake: That's the one.
Lucia:哎卫生站是这样走的吗
Lucia: Hey, is this the way to the clinic?
Shure: i feel like we almost arrived
Shure: I feel like we almost arrived.
Lucia:啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Jake:哎锦州巷子里要
Jake: Hey, in Jinzhou alley...
Lucia:是晚上所以
Lucia: It's night, so...
其他人：你不是信誓旦旦的说
Other: Didn't you confidently say
其他人：已经扔到这边的屋了吗
Other: you already threw it in this room?
Shure: 有锦州烧烤
Shure: There's Jinzhou BBQ.
Lucia:哈哈哈吓了一天
Lucia: Haha, scared all day.
其他人： 过了一天连这里来的地方都不见了
Other: After a day, the place we came from is gone.
Shure: 我们来这吃吧
Shure: Let's eat here.
Jake:哈哈哈整点串吧
Jake: Haha, let's have some skewers.
Shure: 闻着好香啊哈哈哈
Shure: Smells so good, haha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:要不带点串回去吧要不
Jake: How about we take some skewers back?
Lucia:因为昨天那会已经是晚上了
Lucia: Because it was already evening by then.
Lucia:现在这个天色又不认识了
Lucia: Now it's a different time, so it's unrecognizable.
Shure: 闻着好香啊
Shure: Smells so good.
Jake:好香哦
Jake: Smells great.
Jake:你昨天直接走过来也挺挺远我感觉
Jake: You walked all the way here yesterday, it felt pretty far.
其他人:我草我也想吃
Other: Damn, I want to eat too.
Lucia:我总觉得
Lucia: I keep thinking
Lucia:我昨天走的时候好像没这么远
Lucia: it didn't feel this far when I walked yesterday.
Jake:主要旁边没别人
Jake: Mainly because no one else is around.
Lucia:哈哈不是哈哈哈不是真不是
Lucia: Haha, no, haha, really, no.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
其他人:你让我们时间变得很欢乐
Other: You make our time so joyful.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Shure: 欢乐的时光不是总是短暂的吗
Shure: Happy times are always short, right?
其他人:欢乐的时光对
Other: Happy times, yes.
Lucia:他这小路挺多的
Lucia: There are many small paths here.
Lucia:可能昨天走的不是同一个小路
Lucia: Maybe we didn't take the same path yesterday.
Jake:就消耗比较大是吧
Jake: It consumes a lot, right?
Jake:对有点累
Jake: Yes, a bit tiring.
Jake:嘟哒嘟
Jake: Doodah doo.
Shure: 挺好挺好
Shure: Pretty good, pretty good.
Shure: 我今天放弃了
Shure: I gave up today.
Jake:羊汤馆
Jake: Lamb soup shop.
Shure: 卧槽对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 买了彩票
Shure: Bought a lottery ticket.
Shure: 走走走这个珍贵录像得记录一下
Shure: Let's go, let's record this precious footage.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:延吉冷面
Jake: Yanji cold noodles.
Jake:啊买彩票啊
Jake: Ah, buying lottery tickets?
Jake:真买彩票
Jake: Really buying lottery tickets?
其他人:真买
Others: Really buying.
Jake:看看看你刮彩票买买买
Jake: Look, scratch the ticket, buy, buy, buy.
Shure: 要来一个这个 2020
Shure: Let's get one of these, 2020.
其他人:5050 来就来
Others: 5050, let's do it.
其他人:大的怎么这么少报销呢
Others: How come the big ones reimburse so little?
Jake:怎么这么
Jake: How come...
Shure: 报销吗报销
Shure: Reimburse? Reimburse.
其他人:报销不报啊
Others: Reimburse or not?
Jake:报销刮彩票那
Jake: Reimburse for scratching lottery tickets?
Jake:那你刮出来算啥啊
Jake: What does it count as if you scratch it out?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈那那我自费一张20
Shure: Hahaha, then I'll pay for a $20 one myself.
Shure: 来张20的
Shure: Get a $20 one.
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
其他人:这样吧你给我报
Others: How about you reimburse me...
其他人:50我还刮
Others: $50 and I'll scratch.
其他人:刮出来钱都是你的
Others: The money I scratch out is all yours.
其他人:哈哈哈啊
Others: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake:这么回事
Jake: That's how it is.
Shure: 那个打打一注双色
Shure: Let's bet on a double-colored ball.
Shure: 打50块钱双色球
Shure: Bet $50 on the double-colored ball.
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
其他人:我靠你好老
Others: Wow, you're so old.
Katrina: 我靠你好老厉害啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Wow, you're so experienced, hahaha.
其他人:厉害啊哈
Others: So experienced, haha.
Shure: 号是一哎呀
Shure: The number is... oh my.
Shure: 那个146
Shure: It's 146.
Shure: 啊不不
Shure: Ah, no, no.
Shure: 那个红球是146
Shure: The red ball is 146.
Shure: 然后15二七30
Shure: And then 15, 27, 30.
Shure: 然后篮球是
Shure: And the basketball is...
Shure: 我看一眼
Shure: Let me see.
其他人:呵这是能算出来吗
Others: Huh, can this be calculated?
Shure: 篮球双色图
Shure: Basketball double-colored ball.
Shure: 在哪啊这篮球来一个
Shure: Where is it? Let's get a basketball one.
Shure: 来个5吧
Shure: Let's go with 5
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god
Shure: 5倍对5倍
Shure: 5 times against 5 times
Shure: 总共30是吧
Shure: Total is 30, right?
Jake:牛批
Jake: Awesome
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Everyone else:
其他人：给我来一个老板
Everyone: Give me one, boss
其他人:那你戴眼镜
Everyone: Then you wear glasses
Jake:不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no
Jake:不不不这么搞这么搞
Jake: No, no, no, do it like this
其他人:但刮彩票可以很解压
Everyone: But scratching lotto tickets can be very stress-relieving
其他人:如果刮出来就更解压
Everyone: If you win, it's even more stress-relieving
其他人:来吧
Everyone: Come on
其他人:刮出来了
Everyone: Scratched it out
其他人:刮出来就吸了来
Everyone: If you win, take it
其他人:最高奖金80万呢
Everyone: The highest prize is 800,000
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Lucia:让我看看这个的玩法
Lucia: Let me see how this works
其他人:就刮带这个带这个符号的
Everyone: Just scratch the ones with this symbol
其他人:哦这个符号是刮不出来的
Everyone: Oh, this symbol can't be scratched off
其他人:我觉得还有一个我的号码
Everyone: I think there's also my number
其他人:对你先把你的号码刮出来
Everyone: Yeah, scratch your number first
其他人:中奖号码你的号码刮出来
Everyone: Winning number, scratch your number
其他人:嗯那我也刮这个
Everyone: Hmm, then I'll scratch this too
Katrina: 哎我也刮一个吧
Katrina: Hey, I'll scratch one too
其他人:快不行
Everyone: Hurry up, it's not working
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Everyone:
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 他50的
Shure: He's got 50
Jake:哎 50的
Jake: Hey, 50
Jake:你这为什么更牛逼
Jake: Why are you even more awesome?
Katrina: 来来一张20的
Katrina: Come on, give me a 20
其他人:来就来大的
Everyone: Go big or go home
其他人:你中了吗
Everyone: Did you win?
其他人：他有几个铲子啊
Everyone: How many shovels does he have?
Shure: 323134 我这是金铲铲
Shure: 323134, I've got a golden shovel
Jake:就一个铲子 34
Jake: Just one shovel, 34
其他人:我这是金铲子
Everyone: I've got a golden shovel
Jake:呵呵呵不太像
Jake: Hehehe, doesn't look like it.
其他人:他这个没中
Others: He didn't get it.
其他人:记好回本了回本了
Others: Remember, we broke even, we broke even.
Shure: g
Shure: 哦哦回本了
Shure: Oh oh, we broke even.
Shure: 回本我们就必须得继续allin
Shure: Since we broke even, we have to go all in again.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：赌徒我的天啊
Others: Gambler, oh my god.
其他人：你买多少钱
Others: How much did you buy?
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha: 把它搅拌
Tasha: Stir it.
Katrina: 20啊啥意思
Katrina: 20, what's the meaning?
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What does it mean?
其他人：他回本他回本
Others: He broke even, he broke even.
Shure: 就是这个十一嘛
Shure: This is 11.
Shure: 然后这又是十一
Shure: And this is also 11.
Jake:哦对了21哎
Jake: Oh right, 21, hey.
Shure: 然后就获得这20
Shure: And then you get this 20.
Jake:哎呦这贵的就是快刮的
Jake: Oh, the expensive ones are scratched quickly.
其他人: 哦这些这些都能直接换钱
Others: Oh, these can all be exchanged for money directly.
Jake:对啥意思
Jake: Right, what does it mean?
其他人:只要刮出来钱就是钱
Others: As long as you scratch off money, it's money.
Jake:这刮这么多钱啊
Jake: We scratched off so much money?
其他人:就接就是得有彩才行
Others: You just have to get a prize.
Jake:哦那给你写个数字干嘛呀
Jake: Oh, then why write a number for you?
其他人:如果有彩就是下面的钱
Others: If there's a prize, it's the money below.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh oh.
其他人：这概率也太低了吧
Others: The odds are too low.
Jake:是啥意思
Jake: What does it mean?
其他人:就是啥也没有
Others: It means nothing.
其他人:就是鸡的意思
Others: It just means chicken.
Jake:哈哈哈哦
Jake: Hahaha, oh.
Katrina: 还有铁的没
Katrina: Are there any iron ones left?
其他人：我靠
Others: Oh my god.
Jake:啊你这多少钱呢
Jake: Ah, how much is this?
Katrina: 又来一张
Katrina: Another one.
Jake:也是20 也是20
Jake: Also 20, also 20.
其他人：也是20
Others: Also 20.
Katrina: 这不好刮是吧
Katrina: This is hard to scratch, right?
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed
其他人:寄了我怎么感觉寄了
Others: It's over, I feel like it's over
Jake:你这50块钱怎么一
Jake: How come you spent 50 yuan and got nothing
Jake:毛都没有
Jake: Not even a hair
其他人:50块钱寄了
Others: 50 yuan down the drain
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:好可以捐到50是吧
Jake: Okay, can we donate 50?
Jake:福利了我已经逐渐忍住捐了
Jake: I’ve already been gradually resisting donating
其他人: 我已经逐渐忍住捐了50
Others: I’ve already been gradually resisting donating 50
Katrina: 10跟19
Katrina: 10 and 19
其他人：啊 80万
Others: Ah, 800,000
Katrina: 什么东西啊这是
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 这什么哈哈
Katrina: What is this, haha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:啊这要看啥呀
Jake: Ah, what should we look at?
Katrina: 啊不是
Katrina: Ah, no
Shure: 看号
Shure: Look at the number
Katrina: 这是下边
Katrina: This is the bottom
Katrina: 下边才是那个吧
Katrina: The bottom is the one, right?
Katrina: 吓我一跳
Katrina: That scared me
Jake:哈哈哈发财了是吧
Jake: Hahaha, did we just get rich?
Shure: 一般写80万都不会中
Shure: Usually, when it says 800,000, you won’t win
Katrina: 吓我一跳
Katrina: That scared me
Katrina: 真是
Katrina: Really
其他人:但我觉得能刮到写80万的也很不容易
Others: But I think scratching off 800,000 is also not easy
Katrina: 等一下
Katrina: Wait a minute
其他人:已经开始激动了
Others: Starting to get excited
其他人:不是主要是我这一顿隐形眼睛
Others: It’s just that I have only one contact lens in
Katrina: 不是主要是我只有一个隐形眼镜
Katrina: It’s just that I only have one contact lens in
其他人:哦哦哦这样看着直接刮过了
Others: Oh, oh, oh, looking at it like this, it’s scratched off
Katrina: 哈哈哈我看不清啊
Katrina: Haha, I can’t see clearly
Jake:哦你你这个80万你特地不刮是吧
Jake: Oh, you specifically don’t scratch the 800,000 part, right?
Jake:就是你最后再
Jake: You wait until the end
Jake:呵呵呵你最后等着
Jake: Haha, you wait until the end
Katrina: 我不知道刮出来多少
Katrina: I don’t know how much I’ll get
Katrina: 随缘吧我是多少啊
Katrina: Let it be, how much do I have?
Jake:十十是没有
Jake: Ten, ten is nothing
Katrina: 10和19
Katrina: 10 and 19
其他人:哇这中奖率好低啊
Others: Wow, the winning rate is so low
Katrina: 确实图一乐 30
Katrina: Indeed, just for fun, 30
Jake:30哎
Jake: 30, hey
Katrina: 没是不是
Katrina: No, right?
Jake: 那是什么呀
Jake: What is that?
其他人:最上面那个
Others: The one at the top
其他人:万一80万呢
Others: What if it's 800,000?
Shure: 万一就50中了呢
Shure: What if it's just 50 in the middle?
其他人： 最上面那个
Others: The one at the top
Shure: 万一80万80万80万80万
Shure: What if 800,000, 800,000, 800,000, 800,000
Jake:80万看看
Jake: 800,000, let's see
其他人:哇塞差一点
Others: Wow, so close
Jake:差一点差一点
Jake: So close, so close
Jake:哎差点憋出一个哎
Jake: Ah, almost held in one, ah
Katrina: 哈哈哈我来好好好
Katrina: Hahaha, I'll do it, okay, okay
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈老板来一张这个啊
Jake: Hahahahahaha, boss, take a picture of this
Katrina: 完了等会他们说我们怎么还不回去
Katrina: Oh no, wait a minute, they're asking why we haven't gone back yet
Katrina: 在这挂一晚上
Katrina: Hanging out here all night
Katrina: 哈哈老板还有多少人
Katrina: Haha, boss, how many people are left?
Shure: 哈哈哈你要干什么
Shure: Hahaha, what do you want to do?
Katrina: 经费全部
Katrina: All the budget
Shure: 我们经费熬夜
Shure: Our budget, stay up all night
Shure: 这个要么就明天卷铺盖回家
Shure: Either we pack up and go home tomorrow
Shure: 要么我们就经费翻倍好吧
Shure: Or we double the budget, okay?
其他人:哎好久不刮了
Others: Wow, haven't scratched in a long time
其他人:上一次刮可能还是两年之前
Others: Last time might have been two years ago
其他人:没了
Others: That's it
Lucia:哎呀人均一个
Lucia: Ah, one for each
Lucia:那我也买一张吧
Lucia: Then I'll buy one too
Jake:哈哈哈但我压力很大了哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, but I'm really under a lot of pressure, haha
其他人:2634
Others: 2634
Shure: 34
Jake:这钱上哪领啊
Jake: Where do we collect the money?
Shure: 直接跟跟对
Shure: Just directly
Jake:直接直接给是吧哦
Jake: Directly give it, right? Oh
Lucia:我扫您吗
Lucia: Should I scan you?
Lucia:嗯我以为
Lucia: Hmm, I thought
其他人:看日记没有
Others: Did you read the diary?
其他人:没有
Others: No
Shure: 上次跟你同学去刮针刮出500
Shure: Last time you went with your friend, you scratched and got 500
Shure: 他说500的是十十十十十十
Shure: He said the 500 one is all tens, tens, tens.
Shure: 就是全中那种
Shure: It's the one that hits all.
其他人:哇那很厉害
Others: Wow, that's impressive.
其他人:捐了20福利
Others: Donated 20 to welfare.
Jake:捐20
Jake: Donated 20.
Jake:好嘞福利好
Jake: Alright, welfare is good.
Jake:福利福利
Jake: Welfare, welfare.
其他人:他中奖率也太低
Others: His winning rate is too low.
其他人:我之前看过有人刮一本
Others: I saw someone scratch a whole book before.
其他人:刮一本算那个算那个钱
Others: Scratching a whole book counts as money.
其他人:我操又有素材了啊
Others: Damn, there's more material now.
Lucia:哈哈大家既然都买了我也跟一张
Lucia: Haha, since everyone bought one, I'll get one too.
Jake:先看下哪
Jake: Let's see which one.
Jake:一个吧那我很难不买了
Jake: Just one, it's hard not to buy.
其他人:那你跟一个
Others: Then get one.
Jake:那我更个20的
Jake: Then I'll get a 20.
其他人:跟个20
Others: Get a 20.
Jake:这这红的红的和蓝色有什么差别吗
Jake: What's the difference between the red and blue ones?
Jake:没有差别
Jake: No difference.
Lucia:我觉得我都好久没玩过这个了
Lucia: I feel like I haven't played this in so long.
Jake:好那我选一个
Jake: Okay, I'll pick one.
其他人：哎你这数都很近啊
Others: Hey, your numbers are close.
Lucia:哈哈近有什么用呢
Lucia: Haha, what's the use of being close?
其他人：很近像刚刚那个
Others: Very close, like the one just now.
其他人：刚刚那个80万其实也很近
Others: The 800,000 one was actually very close.
Lucia:哎近有什么用呢
Lucia: Hey, what's the use of being close?
Shure: 差点出门就哈哈
Shure: Almost got out, haha.
其他人:差点差点差点差点就可以光荣的从这里离开了
Others: Almost, almost, almost could have left here with glory.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:整个20了吧
Jake: Let's get the 20.
Shure: 20新币的吧整一个
Shure: 20 new dollars, get one.
Jake:那不行整个20新币吧
Jake: No, let's get 20 new dollars.
Jake:那那可不行
Jake: No, that won't do.
Shure: 杨老板好好理智
Shure: Jake is so rational.
其他人:哎他中奖率好
Others: Hey, his winning rate is good.
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 感觉小时候的都比这个年买高一点
Shure: Feels like the ones we got as kids were higher than these years.
其他人:我们连买了123四五张
Others: We bought like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 tickets in a row.
其他人：就就就你中
Others: Only you won.
Shure: 就我第一张中
Shure: Only my first ticket won.
其他人:对啊这概率有点低是吧哈哈好气
Others: Yeah, the probability is a bit low, right? Haha, so frustrating.
Jake:来来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: It's coming, it's coming, it's coming, it's coming.
Shure: 杨老板相信你
Shure: Jake, I believe in you.
Shure: 好中国有句古话叫做
Shure: Well, there's an old Chinese saying...
Jake:屎屎哈哈哈
Jake: Crap, crap, hahaha.
Katrina: 屎
Katrina: Crap.
Shure: 杨老板好干脆啊没有
Shure: Jake is so straightforward, no...
Jake:没
Jake: No.
Jake:没有
其他人:哎哦没有
Others: Oh no, nothing.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Shure: 哎呦没有
Shure: Oh no, nothing.
Shure: 哎呦没
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Jake:哎中了30
Jake: Oh, hit 30.
Shure: 18 哎呦哎呦哎呦哎呦赚10块
Shure: 18, oh, oh, oh, made 10 bucks.
Jake:哎呦哎呦哎呦卖10块
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, sold for 10 bucks.
其他人：赚十块
Others: Made 10 bucks.
Jake:哎呦来看看
Jake: Oh, let's see.
Jake:招招18哎
Jake: It's 18, oh.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
Jake:还是23是吧
Jake: Or is it 23?
Jake:是2327
Jake: It's 23 and 27.
其他人:很难中两个
Others: It's hard to hit two.
其他人:很难中两好
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright.
其他人:还刮吗
Others: Still scratching?
Jake:不刮了不刮了
Jake: No more scratching, no more.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 赚10块
Shure: Made 10 bucks.
Jake:见好见好就收
Jake: Quit while you're ahead.
Jake:见好就收
其他人：我靠他居然见好就收
Others: Wow, he actually quit while he's ahead.
其他人：什么人
Others: What kind of person...
其他人:投资回报率也太低了
Others: The return on investment is too low.
Katrina: 他在菜鸟驿站有说什么时候关门吗
Katrina: Did he say when the Cainiao station closes?
Jake:现在就去吧
Jake: Let's go now.
Jake:就是就在跑隔壁
Jake: Just running next door.
Jake:早知道我们是7点多到
Jake: If we had known earlier, we would have arrived at around 7 o'clock.
Shure: （歌词）为你写诗诗
Shure: (Lyrics) Writing poetry for you.
Shure: （歌词）为你写诗
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 看到了吗
Shure: Did you see it?
Shure: 我们的500万
Shure: Our 5 million.
其他人:不是
Others: No.
Shure: 买这号买了好多好长时间
Shure: We've been buying this number for a long time.
其他人:哦这个这个这个
Others: Oh, this one, this one.
其他人:你是要相信运气的
Others: You have to believe in luck.
其他人:有些人就是一直买一个号
Others: Some people just keep buying one number.
其他人:然后可能突然有一天没买就真的中
Others: And then maybe one day they don't buy it, and they really win.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 号很好
Shure: The number is good.
Jake:他就是在菜鸟驿站没有取
Jake: He didn't pick it up at the delivery station.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Right?
Jake:还是说还有别的地
Jake: Or is there another place?
Lucia:呃还有别的地还有别的地
Lucia: Uh, there are other places, other places.
Jake:别的地
Jake: Other places.
Shure: 京东关了啊
Shure: JD is closed.
Katrina: 京东我不是京东
Katrina: JD? I'm not with JD.
Jake:那你在这先排
Jake: Then queue here first.
Jake:我到前面看看去
Jake: I'll go check up front.
Katrina: 喂你好
Katrina: Hello?
Jake:前面可能还有一个口
Jake: There might be another entrance up front.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: Another one.
Katrina: 嗯嗯然后然后我是那个31号
Katrina: Mm-hmm, and I'm number 31.
Katrina: 你从那个53往右拐进去
Katrina: Turn right from 53.
Katrina: 那个绿色房子就是
Katrina: The green house is right there.
Katrina: 就在他后面
Katrina: It's behind it.
Katrina: 呃我们是31号那个绿色的
Katrina: Uh, we are number 31, the green one.
Katrina: 嗯就是你站在那个路口然后往右看
Katrina: Yeah, stand at the intersection and look to the right.
Jake:是有一个小豁口
Jake: There's a small gap.
Jake:这豁口里边有一个你记得不
Jake: Inside that gap, there's something, do you remember?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Jake:就是我们
Jake: That's us.
其他人:哦那天后面去那个
Others: Oh, that day we went to the back.
Katrina: 五五十一在我们旁边吗
Katrina: Is 51 next to us?
Jake:对对对一堆保安那个
Jake: Yeah, a bunch of security guards.
其他人:一堆保安那个
Others: A bunch of security guards there
Shure: 51室
Shure: Room 51
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Katrina: 51
其他人:从51往那个51往里走
Others: From 51, walk inside
Shure: 从51往那个里面的那个胡同走就是
Shure: From 51, you walk into that alley
Katrina: 51往那个胡同走
Katrina: Walk into that alley from 51
Katrina: 然后就是31
Katrina: Then it's 31
Katrina: 好谢谢
Katrina: Alright, thanks
Katrina: 麻烦你
Katrina: Sorry for the trouble
Jake:那我先看一眼这然后要不就在那
Jake: Let me take a look here first, or maybe there
Katrina: 你放门口就行
Katrina: Just leave it at the door
Jake:反正是在这附近
Jake: Anyway, it's around here
Katrina: 那我们现在去哪
Katrina: So where are we going now?
Katrina: 菜鸟驿站吗
Katrina: To the Cainiao Station?
Shure: 你是在菜鸟驿站吗
Shure: Are you at the Cainiao Station?
Katrina: 我呃我是菜鸟驿站
Katrina: Uh, I am at the Cainiao Station
Shure: 那你跟他排队去
Shure: Then you go line up with him
Lucia:在这边吗
Lucia: Is it over here?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
其他人：楼下
Others: Downstairs
其他人：8182您看有吗
Others: 8182, do you see it?
其他人：没有好谢
Others: No, thanks
其他人：9184
Others: 9184
其他人：手机尾号9184
Others: Phone number ending in 9184
其他人：对
Others: Yes
其他人：叫什么名字
Others: What's the name?
其他人：张梦瑶
Others: Zhang Mengyao
Lucia: 觉得好像有蚊子
Lucia: Feels like there are mosquitoes
Katrina: 我也是
Katrina: Me too
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thanks
Lucia: 呃你好那个62600 1
Lucia: Uh, hello, that 62600 1
其他人：收件人叫什么
Others: Who's the recipient?
Lucia: 呃朱先生然后还有还有那个846003
Lucia: Uh, Mr. Zhu, and also 846003
Lucia:还有一个四四6003
Lucia: And another one, four four 6003
其他人：四多少
Others: Four what?
Lucia:6003
Lucia: 6003
其他人：看哪个
Others: Which one?
其他人：3个6多少
Others: 3 sixes what?
其他人：啊
Others: Ah
Lucia:然后我这有个申通
Lucia: So I have a Shentong package here.
Lucia:他显示的是已签收
Lucia: It shows that it has been signed for.
Lucia:但是我觉得还是在驿站
Lucia: But I think it's still at the station.
Lucia:因为他没有给我送货上门
Lucia: Because they didn't deliver it to my door.
Lucia:您看一眼是在这嗯
Lucia: Can you check if it's here?
Lucia:这是哪个东西
Lucia: Which item is this?
Lucia:我都忘了
Lucia: I forgot.
其他人：下回下回再给你打电话
Other person: I'll call you next time.
其他人：送上门你问他
Other person: Ask them to deliver it to your door.
Lucia:行行好嘞
Lucia: Okay, got it.
Lucia:哈哈哈谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, thanks.
Lucia:就是他应该给我送货上门啊
Lucia: They should deliver it to my door.
Lucia:他显示我签收
Lucia: It shows that I signed for it.
Lucia:您看一眼
Lucia: Can you check?
Lucia:这个是在这不
Lucia: Is it here?
其他人：这个不是
Other person: It's not here.
其他人：这个在那边
Other person: It's over there.
其他人：那个院子那边
Other person: By the yard over there.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Lucia:他说这个新城分布
Lucia: They said it's at the new town distribution.
Lucia:这个是在那边
Lucia: It's over there.
Katrina: 哦哦30呃十3-15005
Katrina: Oh, oh, 30 uh, 13-15005.
Katrina: 1715-7601一羊
Katrina: 1715-7601, a sheep.
Katrina: 嗯15-7 还有多少 6011
Katrina: Hmm, 15-7, how many more, 6011.
Lucia:那我我今天就差另外的那个了
Lucia: So I'm just missing the other one today.
Katrina: 我今天就差另外的那个了
Katrina: I'm just missing the other one today.
Katrina: 其实还有俩还没到
Katrina: Actually, there are two more that haven't arrived.
Lucia:我也是
Lucia: Same here.
Katrina: 嗯对还有一个1-1
Katrina: Yeah, there's one more, 1-1.
Katrina: 六零零六零零六
Katrina: 6006006.
Katrina: 幺杠幺六零零6
Katrina: 1-1, 6006.
Lucia: security
Lucia: Security.
Katrina: 这是我的小小那个狐狸
Katrina: This is my little fox.
Katrina: 在这拆
Katrina: Unboxing it here.
Katrina: 还有一个8-46028
Katrina: And there's another one, 8-46028.
Katrina: 刚好都在菜鸟
Katrina: Just happened to be at Cainiao.
Katrina: 8-4对
Katrina: 8-4, yeah.
其他人：不是吗我们这的吧
Other person: Isn't it? It's ours, right?
Katrina: 不是吗他显示菜鸟驿站
Katrina: Isn't it? It shows it's at Cainiao station.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 菜鸟驿站31号房哪去了
Katrina: Where's room 31 at the CaiNiao station?
其他人：哪去了
Others: Where did it go?
Katrina: 31号房在哪啊我都不知道
Katrina: Where's room 31? I don't even know.
Katrina: 啊不是你们这吗
Katrina: Isn't it supposed to be here?
其他人：你点开看看地址在哪吧
Others: Why don't you check the address?
其他人：60这不8-46028吗
Others: Look, isn't it 8-46028?
Katrina: 啊8-46028
Katrina: Oh, 8-46028.
Katrina: 他也不知道他自己是31号 房
Katrina: He doesn't even know he's in room 31.
Katrina: 快递盒子可以给他扔哪
Katrina: Where can I throw away this package box?
Lucia: 应该可以扔这或者先回收吧
Lucia: You can probably throw it here or just recycle it.
Katrina: OK谢谢你还有吗
Katrina: OK, thanks. Is there anything else?
Lucia: 我好了我就差那个
Lucia: I'm good, just missing that one thing.
Katrina: 我靠我特害怕把他摔坏
Katrina: Gosh, I'm really scared of breaking it.
Lucia: 我觉得他们应该经经就是做过那个压
Lucia: I think they probably did some stress tests.
Katrina: 各种压力测试吧
Katrina: Various stress tests, right?
Katrina: 嗯主要是这玩意太
Katrina: Yeah, but this thing is just too...
Katrina: 明天还是找管家来去
Katrina: Let's have the manager deal with it tomorrow.
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 有的时候快递多觉
Katrina: Sometimes, having too many deliveries...
Katrina: 得其实是一种麻烦
Katrina: ...is actually kind of a hassle.
Katrina: 我在学校也是
Katrina: Even at school...
Katrina: 我在学校快递多
Katrina: I get a lot of deliveries.
Katrina: 因为我们宿舍离菜鸟驿站特别远
Katrina: Our dorm is really far from the CaiNiao station.
Lucia: 这个地方是新城分部
Lucia: This place is the Xincheng branch.
Katrina: 那急吗不急
Katrina: Is it urgent? Not really.
Katrina: 明天让管家帮你取呗
Katrina: You can have the manager pick it up tomorrow.
Katrina: 喂
Katrina: Hello?
Katrina: 喂在哪啊
Katrina: Hello, where are you?
Shure: 百世的那个是什么快递啊
Shure: What kind of delivery is that from Best Express?
Katrina: 百世的谁啊
Katrina: Who's the one from Best Express?
Lucia: 百世的是我的
Lucia: The Best Express one is mine.
Shure:  另一个另一个驿站应该是我的
Shure: The other station one should be mine.
Lucia: 应该是我的
Lucia: It should be mine.
Lucia: 呃是那个
Lucia: Uh, it's that one.
Lucia: 稍等一下啊
Lucia: Just a moment.
Katrina: 呃是
Katrina: Uh, yes.
Lucia: 行行好嘞好嘞
Lucia: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 我们去找他吗
Katrina: Should we go find him?
Lucia: 我发给秀硕是吧
Lucia: I'll send it to Shure, right?
其他人：走吧
Others: Let's go.
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 不知道我现在是独眼侠
Katrina: You know I'm a cyclops now.
Lucia:你只带了一个隐形
Lucia: You only have one contact in.
Katrina: 对好奇怪那个盒子已经没有
Katrina: Yeah, it's so weird, the other one is missing.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:带一个隐形的话会就是既清楚又模糊
Lucia: Wearing just one contact lens makes things both clear and blurry.
Katrina: 对会有点头晕
Katrina: Yeah, it makes me a bit dizzy.
Lucia:语音通话一下问问他们在哪
Lucia: Try calling them, ask where they are.
Katrina: 我们刚从那边来的
Katrina: We just came from that way.
Katrina: 是吧我们这样走过去
Katrina: Right, we'll just walk over.
Lucia:对咱们刚从那边来的
Lucia: Yeah, we just came from there.
Katrina: 慢慢走过去
Katrina: Let's walk slowly.
Lucia:截图
Lucia: Screenshot.
Lucia:等一下修硕
Lucia: Wait a sec, Shure.
Lucia:我给他截个图
Lucia: I'll take a screenshot for him.
Katrina: 明天给你看看我装饰的房间
Katrina: I'll show you the room I decorated tomorrow.
Lucia:我网卡了靠
Lucia: My connection lagged, damn.
Lucia:不过应该是没有别的了
Lucia: But that should be all.
Lucia:没有了就这个
Lucia: That's it, just this one.
Lucia:谢谢你们是在哪边
Lucia: Thanks, where are you guys?
Lucia:是我和雨轩过去
Lucia: Should Rain and I come over?
Lucia:还是你们一会还从这条路回来
Lucia: Or are you guys coming back this way?
Lucia:嗯嗯
Lucia: Uh-huh.
Lucia:我买这渔网他说给我送土丁了
Lucia: I bought this fishing net, and he said he'd give me hooks.
Lucia:一会让我看看他送没送
Lucia: Let me check if he did.
Lucia:怎么感觉摸着没有呢
Lucia: Why does it feel like there aren't any?
Katrina: 土丁土丁能弄墙上吗
Katrina: Can hooks be used on the wall?
Lucia:啊不弄墙就是
Lucia: Ah, not for the wall.
Lucia:我有一我买了一个那种照片墙啊对
Lucia: I bought a photo wall, yes.
Katrina: 哦哦就行
Katrina: Oh, that's fine then.
Lucia:但是就他肯定还得往墙上固定一下
Lucia: But it needs to be fixed to the wall.
Lucia:因为这个东西比照片墙要大
Lucia: It's bigger than a photo wall.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia:所以我打算用美纹纸贴一下
Lucia: So I'll use masking tape to stick it.
Katrina: 我之前好像也看见过这种
Katrina: I think I've seen that before.
Katrina: 什么在墙上的
Katrina: Something on the wall.
Katrina: 照片墙那种
Katrina: Like a photo wall.
Lucia:因为我其实一直想给我自己的卧室
Lucia: Because I've always wanted to make one for my bedroom.
Lucia:也弄一个
Lucia: A photo wall.
Lucia:照片墙
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 到时候咱们直接无痛迁移就行
Katrina: We can just move everything painlessly then.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:等到把这些都拆下来
Lucia: When we take all these down,
Lucia:我就把家里能用的给他带走
Lucia: I'll take whatever's usable from home.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 他们怎么说
Katrina: What did they say?
Lucia:看一眼好像还没回复
Lucia: Let me check, seems like they haven't replied yet.
Lucia:也可能是我网不太好
Lucia: Maybe my connection is bad.
Lucia:不知发出去没
Lucia: Not sure if it sent.
Lucia:我已经被咬了
Lucia: I've been bitten.
Katrina: 我也是
Katrina: Me too.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 怎么说我们往那走还是怎么
Katrina: So, should we head over there or what?
Lucia:他还没回我
Lucia: He hasn't replied to me yet.
Lucia:要不给他打个电话
Lucia: Maybe we should call him.
Lucia:语音通话
Lucia: Voice call.
Lucia:不会是他网不好吧哈哈
Lucia: Maybe it's his connection that's bad, haha.
Lucia:那可能他们就过来了
Lucia: Maybe they're on their way.
其他人：谁弄的谁弄的找打那个小孩
Others: Who did that? Find the kid who did it.
Lucia:怎么一个个都不接电话呀
Lucia: Why is nobody answering the phone?
Katrina: 走吧我们往回走吧
Katrina: Let's head back.
Lucia:我觉得有可
Lucia: I think it might be...
Lucia:嗯刚想说有可能是我网不好
Lucia: Hmm, I was just about to say it might be my connection.
Katrina: 不对
Katrina: No, that's not right.
Lucia:然后转了一下圈又发出去了
Lucia: Then I sent it again after refreshing.
Lucia:那他们应该能收到
Lucia: They should get it now.
Lucia:他们网不好
Lucia: Their connection is bad.
Katrina: 他们被拐到哪里去了
Katrina: Where did they get lost?
Katrina: 好冷啊晚上我要回家衣服
Katrina: It's so cold, I need to go home for clothes tonight.
Lucia:我也晚上是有点冷
Lucia: Yeah, it's a bit chilly at night.
Katrina: 嗯白天好热
Katrina: Yeah, but it's so hot during the day.
Lucia:哎那个是他们吗
Lucia: Hey, is that them?
Katrina: 路灯多了些
Katrina: There are more street lights.
Lucia:有好几个人
Lucia: There are quite a few people.
Lucia:那有好几个人是他们吗
Lucia: Are those people them?
Lucia:是不是人数比他们要多一些好像
Lucia: Are there more people than them?
Lucia:感觉不是
Lucia: I don't think so.
Lucia:应该是别人
Lucia: It should be someone else.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 我给谢修主我给谢谢宾主打电
Katrina: I'll call Xie Xiu, I'll call Xie Bin.
Lucia:看看他手机能不能接到
Lucia: Let's see if his phone can pick it up.
Katrina: 他应该会一直吧
Katrina: He should be able to, right?
Lucia:咋回事啊这些人
Lucia: What's up with these people?
Katrina: 奇怪
Katrina: Weird.
Katrina: 事情有点不对劲
Katrina: Something seems off.
Lucia:对吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 设置一点悬疑的点
Katrina: Let's add a bit of suspense.
Katrina: 不会又去那个彩票店了
Katrina: Could they have gone to the lottery store again?
Lucia:不能吧他们不会被拐卖了吧
Lucia: No way, they couldn't have been trafficked, right?
Lucia:这么多个男生
Lucia: So many guys.
Lucia:也不是随便能拐卖的了的吧
Lucia: It's not easy to traffic them casually, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia:哎修硕又打回来了
Lucia: Hey, Shure is calling back.
Lucia:在这干嘛呢
Lucia: What are you doing there?
Lucia:哈喽哈喽
Lucia: Hello, hello.
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Hey.
Katrina: 才给我打过来
Katrina: Just called me back.
Lucia:网络异常
Lucia: Network issue.
Lucia:通话结束
Lucia: Call ended.
Katrina: 喂
Katrina: Hello?
Katrina: 喂你在哪呢
Katrina: Hello, where are you?
Shure: 你们在哪
Shure: Where are you guys?
Katrina: 你们在哪
Katrina: Where are you guys?
Shure: 你们还在快递站吗
Shure: Are you still at the delivery station?
Lucia:哎哎他们在那边
Lucia: Hey, hey, they're over there.
Lucia:他们在那边
Lucia: They're over there.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:我们也觉得你们应该在刮彩票
Jake: We thought you guys might be scratching lottery tickets.
Katrina: 奇怪
Katrina: Weird.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:刚才雨轩还说
Lucia: Just now, Yuxuan said.
Lucia:他们不会又去彩票店了吧哈哈
Lucia: They might have gone to the lottery store again, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia:我刚接上你电话就网络异常又断了
Lucia: I just connected your call, then the network issue happened, and it got cut off.
Shure: 我以
Shure: I thought.
Shure: 为你不接
Shure: You didn't pick up.
Shure: 然后就给雨轩打
Shure: So I called Yuxuan.
Shure: 看人家秒接你怎么回事
Shure: Look how fast he replied to you, what's going on?
Shure: 反思一下
Shure: Reflect on it.
Lucia:这不是网络异常吗
Lucia: Isn't it a network issue?
Shure: 那他的网络怎么不异常
Shure: Why isn't his network having issues?
Shure: 怎么全班就你一个人网络异常呢
Shure: Why is it just you having network issues in the whole class?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈好好味
Katrina: Hahaha, it's so funny!
Lucia:那我们俩运营商不一样呗
Lucia: Maybe we have different service providers.
Katrina: 太冲了哈哈哈
Katrina: That's too much, hahaha!
Shure: 那他怎么知道选那好的运营商
Shure: How did he know to pick a good service provider?
Shure: 你不知道呢
Shure: And you didn't?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia:不是你挑我运营商毛病
Lucia: Are you criticizing my service provider?
Katrina: 你挑我运营商
Katrina: You're criticizing my provider?
Lucia:你怎么不去跟运营商对峙一下呢
Lucia: Why don't you confront the provider then?
Lucia:是吧哈哈
Lucia: Right? Haha
其他人：顶嘴了是吧就会顶嘴
Others: Oh, so you're talking back now? All you do is talk back.
Lucia:你让他你让他把这哈哈哈
Lucia: Why don't you ask them to improve the service, hahaha.
Lucia:你让他把这服务一改进一
Lucia: Ask them to improve the service.
Lucia:黑我这接你电话就秒接是吧
Lucia: So I can answer your calls instantly, right?
Lucia:哎呦又掉啊
Lucia: Oh no, it dropped again.
Lucia:这玩意已经今天掉了无数次了
Lucia: This thing has dropped countless times today.
Lucia:虽然从我拿上他到现在为止
Lucia: Even though I've only had it for less than 10 minutes.
Lucia:还不超过10分钟
Lucia: It's been less than 10 minutes since I got it.
Shure: 没有共产党
Shure: Without the Communist Party...
Katrina: 修硕帮我拿个这个呗
Katrina: Shure, could you help me get this?
Katrina: 因为它滑动摩擦力有点大
Katrina: It's got a bit of sliding friction.
Katrina: 哇这样就是
Katrina: Wow, this is...
Katrina: 噔噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Shure: （歌词）夏天夏天悄悄过去
Shure: (Lyrics) Summer, summer, quietly passing by.
Shure: （歌词）留下小秘密压心底
Shure: (Lyrics) Leaving little secrets, deep in the heart.
Jake:咱也拿点吧
Jake: Let's get some too.
Jake:给咱拿点
Jake: Get us some.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Katrina: 壁画
Katrina: A mural.
其他人：看起来还是没有狐狸
Others: Still doesn't look like a fox.
Lucia:狐狸在哪啊
Lucia: Where's the fox?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈这已经这样子出门了
Katrina: Hahaha, he's already going out like this.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:这是围巾
Jake: Is this a scarf?
Jake:这是围巾吗
Katrina: 不是不是
Katrina: No, no.
Katrina: 围巾要单独买
Katrina: Scarves need to be bought separately.
Lucia:这是狐狸
Lucia: This is a fox.
其他人：狐狸的围巾
Others: A fox scarf.
Katrina: 围巾还没发货呢
Katrina: The scarf hasn't been shipped yet.
Katrina: 来不及了
Katrina: It's too late.
Jake:这是个烟花吗
Jake: Is this a firework?
Jake:能买烟花吗
Jake: Can we buy fireworks?
Jake:买烟花吧
Jake: Let's buy fireworks.
Jake:买烟花放烟花
Jake: Buy fireworks and set them off.
Katrina: 过年
Katrina: For New Year.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:你们那里给放烟花吧
Jake: Can you set off fireworks there?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 我们今年可以
Shure: This year we can.
Shure: 前几年都不行
Shure: The past few years we couldn't.
Jake:南洋理工不能放
Jake: At Nanyang Tech, we can't.
Jake:军事的管制区
Jake: It's a military control area.
其他人:但我看之前嘴也不是会放仙女棒啊
Others: But I saw they were still setting off sparklers before.
Jake:仙女棒算什么东西
Jake: Sparklers don't count.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:啊哪个组委会
Lucia: Ah, which committee?
其他人:所以我好奇
Others: So I'm curious.
其他人:现在他有人陪了
Others: Does he have someone with him now?
其他人:你们过年还会去她家吗
Others: Will you still go to her house for New Year?
Jake:去啊去啊
Jake: Yes, we'll go.
Jake:只有过年能见到他了
Jake: We can only see him during New Year.
Jake:就是我老板
Jake: He's my boss.
Jake:就这个给钱的大老板
Jake: The one who gives us money.
Jake:他这个谈恋爱之前天天跟我们吃饭
Jake: Before he started dating, he used to have meals with us every day.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:午饭和晚饭都够我们吃
Jake: Both lunch and dinner were on him.
Jake:谈恋爱之后就过年见着一次
Jake: After he started dating, we only see him during New Year.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈他多大年纪啊
Katrina: Haha, how old is he?
Shure: 怎么这个样子呢
Shure: How did it turn out like this?
其他人:所以他他不是刚谈吧
Others: So he just started dating, right?
Jake:没有他他女朋友从美国回来了对
Jake: No, his girlfriend came back from the USA.
其他人:America
Others: America.
其他人:居然是America
Others: Really, America?
Shure: 美利坚
Shure: America.
其他人:他女朋友是我们这个领域的吗
Others: Is his girlfriend in our field?
Jake:不算是思科
Jake: Not really, she works at Cisco.
Shure: Cisco这段说实话
Shure: Cisco? Honestly...
Jake:cisco
Jake: Cisco.
Shure: 非常的形象
Shure: Very descriptive.
Katrina: 啊你好有职业素养啊
Katrina: Ah, you are so professional.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这段
Katrina: Haha, this part...
Shure: 说实话
Shure: Honestly...
其他人:嗯可以不记这段
Others: Hmm, maybe we should skip this part.
Shure: Cisco不能叫
Jake:美国那怎么说
Jake: Then what should we call it?
Shure: 他应该叫
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:这也太要紧了
Jake: That's too much.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Katrina: 好牛啊
Katrina: So cool.
Shure: 他不如华为啊
Shure: It's not as good as Huawei.
Shure: 不行吗行
Shure: Can't we say that?
Jake:行没问题没问题
Jake: It's okay, no problem.
Jake:硬件设备
Jake: Hardware equipment.
其他人:硬件设备供应商吗
Others: Hardware equipment supplier?
Jake:你华为做什么了
Jake: What does Huawei do?
Jake:他不做手机
Jake: They don't make phones.
Jake:除了别的
Jake: Except for other things.
其他人:这个华为不是
Others: This Huawei isn't...
Jake:我靠那什么东西啊我靠
Jake: What the heck, what are you talking about?
Jake:行我们换个话题好吧
Jake: Alright, let's change the topic.
Shure: 哈哈哈越来越不能播
Shure: Hahaha, it's getting unbroadcastable.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
其他人:所以所以他
Others: So, so he...
其他人:他女朋友回来就要定居在新加坡了
Others: His girlfriend is going to settle in Singapore now.
Jake:是吧哎呀
Jake: Right, oh man.
Shure: 哎呀我今天晚上7点有个会啊
Shure: Oh man, I have a meeting at 7 PM tonight.
其他人:牛逼还好
Others: Wow, that's impressive.
其他人:像我会一般都安排到晚上10点半之后
Others: My meetings are usually scheduled after 10:30 PM.
其他人:可是我不会忘了
Others: But I won't forget.
Jake:啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Oh, are you still struggling?
Jake:他7点的会还要挣扎吗
Jake: Are you still struggling with your 7 PM meeting?
其他人：是你要讲吗你要不讲你就
Others: Are you the one speaking? If not, then...
Jake:也不用了吧
Jake: No need, right?
Lucia:这不都7:46了吗
Lucia: Isn't it already 7:46?
Jake:对啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Yeah, are you still struggling?
Shure: 我是主持人
Shure: I'm the host.
Shure: 我是社长啊哈哈哈
Shure: I'm the president, haha.
Jake:哦有人找你是吧
Jake: Oh, someone is looking for you, right?
Lucia:那完了大家已经等了你46分钟了
Lucia: Then it's over, everyone has been waiting for you for 46 minutes.
Jake:你说你你取快递
Jake: You said you were picking up a package.
Katrina: 你这耍大牌呀
Katrina: You're acting like a big shot.
Jake:取快递取46分钟没问题
Jake: Picking up a package for 46 minutes, no problem.
Katrina: 直接46分钟
Katrina: Directly 46 minutes.
Shure: 我刚才公司给我突然来了个电话
Shure: My company just gave me a sudden call.
Katrina: 往哪走
Katrina: Where are you going?
Jake:对对都能走都能走
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you can go anywhere.
Shure: 刚lida突然
Shure: Just now, Lida suddenly...
Shure: 给我派了个活
Shure: Gave me some work.
Shure: 我一下忙忙忙忘了
Shure: I got so busy I forgot.
Lucia:啥啊
Lucia: What?
Katrina: 他说丽特给他派活了
Katrina: He said Lida gave him work.
Katrina: 他忙忘了
Katrina: He got busy and forgot.
Jake:嗯嗯确实
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it happens.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia:确实
Lucia: It really does.
Katrina: 是啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 丽达让你出来取快递你就说
Katrina: If Lida asked you to pick up a package, you'd say...
其他人:你这样说你就说啊
Others: You'd just say...
其他人:刚才丽特给我呃安排了一下
Others: Just now, Lida assigned me some work.
其他人:明天我们要上线一个party
Others: We have a party going live tomorrow.
其他人:刚刚和同事们对齐了一下
Others: I was aligning with my colleagues.
其他人:所以搞的比较晚
Others: So it got a bit late.
其他人:什么行业
Others: What industry?
其他人:黑花
Others: Black flowers.
Jake:呵你要说特殊情况
Jake: Hehe, you're talking about special circumstances.
Jake:见着个狐狸
Jake: Seeing a fox.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:狐狸去了哈哈哈
Lucia: The fox left, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:对对有点不巧
Jake: Yeah, it's a bit unfortunate.
Lucia:好冷啊我天
Lucia: It's so cold, oh my god.
Shure: 哎为什么今天吃水饺
Shure: Hey, why are we eating dumplings today?
Shure: 不是昨天
Shure: Wasn't it yesterday?
Jake:哎呦阿丽丽
Jake: Oh, Alice.
Shure: 是谷雨吧
Shure: It's Grain Rain, right?
Lucia:希望这几玩意拆开颜色没有色差
Lucia: Hope these things don't have a color difference when unpacked.
其他人:我们我们往常是几点开始弄啊
Others: When do we usually start doing this?
Lucia:要不然我就系了哈
Lucia: Otherwise, I'll tie it up.
Jake:晚上咱现在就在开始弄
Jake: We'll start doing it tonight.
其他人:那那晚上一般几点钟弄完
Others: So, when do we usually finish at night?
Jake:这个很难讲
Jake: It's hard to say.
其他人:还有一场吗
Others: Is there another round?
Jake:今晚没了
Jake: No more tonight.
Jake:今晚就收拾收拾嘛
Jake: We'll just clean up tonight.
Jake:拆拆快递嘛
Jake: Unpack some packages.
Jake:随便拍拍嘛
Jake: And casually take some photos.
其他人:那我约 10点半
Others: Then I'll schedule it for 10:30.
Jake:你可以约
Jake: You can schedule it.
Jake:你随便什么时候约
Jake: You can schedule it anytime.
其他人:是啊他爷爷不就说嘛
Others: Yeah, his grandpa said so.
其他人:孩子长大了
Others: The kid's grown up.
其他人:等他回到家那个
Others: When he comes home,
其他人:跟他回去
Others: He'll go with him.
Katrina: 这还挺漂亮哈
Katrina: This is quite beautiful.
其他人:台球啊哈哈
Others: Billiards, haha.
其他人:我的台球是
Others: My billiards is...
Shure: 我可以
Shure: I can...
Shure: 我帮你整治
Shure: I can help you organize.
Jake:啊工作不饱和啊
Jake: Ah, the work is not saturated.
Shure: 刘帅好吧
Shure: Choiszt, right?
Jake:工作不饱和
Jake: The work is not saturated.
Jake:看着
Jake: Look at it.
其他人:什么叫工作不饱和
Others: What does "work is not saturated" mean?
Lucia:还有时间打台球
Lucia: There's still time to play billiards.
其他人:啊昨天已经过饱和了
Others: Ah, yesterday was already oversaturated.
其他人:好嘞你知道我整个人都快要结晶了
Others: Alright, you know, I'm almost crystallized.
Lucia:结晶了哈哈哈
Lucia: Crystallized, hahaha.
Jake:呵呵你这是怎么讲
Jake: Haha, what do you mean by that?
Jake:脱水了是吗
Jake: Dehydrated, right?
Shure: 那个是那什么
Shure: What's that, what?
其他人:妈的台球海底捞
Others: Damn, billiards at Haidilao.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure: 台球海底捞
Shure: Billiards at Haidilao.
Shure: 你猜对
Shure: You guessed it right.
其他人:台球海底捞
Others: Billiards at Haidilao.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
其他人:这么牛逼啊
Others: That's so awesome.
Jake:多少钱多少钱
Jake: How much, how much?
其他人:也不贵不贵
Others: It's not expensive, not expensive.
其他人:就是正常价
Others: Just the regular price.
Jake:哎我们要拐了
Jake: Hey, we need to make a turn.
其他人:那这种台阶
Others: Then these steps...
Lucia:在这拐
Lucia: Turn here.
其他人:都不会把别人杀的毫无还手之力
Others: Won't leave others defenseless.
其他人:哎这边这边不往前走两下都行
Others: Hey, this way, this way, just walk a few steps forward.
Lucia:还是停一下
Lucia: Let's stop for a moment.
其他人:都行吗要不就晚了
Others: Is it okay? Otherwise, it'll be too late.
Jake:这边拐可以啊
Jake: Turning here is fine.
Jake:那就这么拐吧
Jake: Then let's turn here.
其他人:百球小生会观察你
Others: The billiard prodigy will watch you.
Shure: 我一会去群里说一下
Shure: I'll mention it in the group later.
其他人:你要是这一球要用上加盖了
Others: If you need to use the cover for this shot...
Shure: 实在不好意思
Shure: Really sorry about that.
其他人:他主动帮你把加盖抬起来
Others: He'll actively lift the cover for you.
其他人:我双手递给你
Others: I'll hand it to you with both hands.
其他人:那加盖用完了
Others: The cover is used up.
其他人:那双手递回来
Others: Then hand it back with both hands.
其他人:那别的排气
Others: Where's the other exhaust?
其他人:那别的台球生存空间在哪呢
Others: Where's the living space for other billiards?
其他人:我不知道啊
Others: I don't know.
其他人:我以后肯定只去银川
Others: I'll definitely only go to Yinchuan in the future.
其他人:太逆天了
Others: It's too amazing.
其他人:对于一个小城市出来的我
Others: For someone from a small town like me...
其他人:我去哈哈哈
Others: Oh, man, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
其他人:留下一部位
Others: Leave one spot
其他人:留下金爷就比较会享受啊
Others: Leave it to Jin, he really knows how to enjoy it
其他人:他说下次
Others: He said next time
Shure: 79一小时
Shure: 79 per hour
其他人:他说下次带我去个更好的地方
Others: He said next time he'll take me to a better place
其他人:哦不是你可以美谈美观啊
Others: Oh, you can make it nice and pretty
其他人:确实今天要坐一下刘帅
Others: Indeed, today we need to sit on Choiszt
其他人:让我让我看看刘帅开奔驰是什么样子
Others: Let me see what it's like when Choiszt drives a Mercedes
其他人:但是开奔驰的人会不会变帅
Others: But will driving a Mercedes make you handsome?
Shure: 我靠他那个后排的空间巨大
Shure: Wow, the back seat is huge
Shure: 真就是给老板坐的巨爽
Shure: It's really just made for the boss, super comfortable
Shure: 而且你后排是可以瞧前排座椅的
Shure: And you can see the front seats from the back
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahahaha, okay
其他人:非常的人性化
Others: Very user-friendly
Shure: 不会像那个捷达你连找找都找不着
Shure: It's not like a Jetta where you can't even find things
其他人:我的手就是找条达到胳膊
Others: My hand just reached for the armrest
Shure: 一看就没开过
Shure: Clearly never driven one
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Shure: 少爷就是没开过这种手动咔咔咔的车
Shure: This young master has never driven a manual car
Shure: 哎太金贵了少爷
Shure: Too precious, young master
其他人：他奔驰手动挡
Others: He has a manual Mercedes
其他人：如果没有学法减分我马上就好回去学手动挡车了
Others: If there were no penalty points, I'd go back and learn to drive a manual car right away
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Lucia:这灯的配色也太
Lucia: The color scheme of this light is just too
Jake:撞色
Jake: Clashing
Lucia:也行吧
Lucia: It's okay
Jake:哈哈独特的设计
Jake: Haha, unique design
Katrina: 就是刚刚那个happy birthday
Katrina: It's just that "Happy Birthday" earlier
Jake:给他唱一段
Jake: Sing a part for him
其他人:喝酒喝吐了
Others: Drank till he puked
其他人:只喝一分钟
Others: Only drank for a minute
Lucia:那只要沉默1分钟就好了
Lucia: Then we just need to stay silent for a minute
其他人：这就是禁言的生活
Others: This is what life on mute is like
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha
Shure: 香椿天妇罗
Shure: Toon tempura
Shure: 我天
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 哎sorry sorry
Shure: Hey, sorry, sorry
Shure: 一般那粥都得自己加
Shure: Usually, you have to add to the porridge yourself
Jake:北极能看到星星
Jake: You can see stars at the North Pole.
Shure: 通州沙河都能看到星星
Shure: You can see stars in Tongzhou and Shahe too.
Jake:哦不是北京是吧
Jake: Oh, not Beijing, right?
Shure: 哎能能能
Shure: Yes, you can, you can.
Shure: 不不这算
Shure: No, no, it counts.
Shure: 北京这这场地也记一下
Shure: Let's mark this spot in Beijing too.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 他试图分裂北京
Shure: He’s trying to divide Beijing.
其他人：分裂北京不如你这个小华为
Others: Dividing Beijing is like your little Huawei.
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: This, hahaha.
Jake:就你这个迹象哈哈哈
Jake: Just like your signs, hahaha.
Shure: 然后我小时吃这种
Shure: I used to eat this when I was a kid.
Jake:梅开二度
Jake: Scored twice.
Shure: 然后加了还不让加
Shure: And adding more, but they didn’t allow it.
Shure: 就是我们家基本什么东西都不让加
Shure: Basically, we couldn’t add anything at home.
Jake:给一个给一个
Jake: Give one, give one.
Shure: 糖什么的
Shure: Like sugar.
Shure: 就觉得不健康
Shure: They thought it was unhealthy.
Jake:谢谢没有没有
Jake: Thanks, no no.
Jake:说他
Jake:梅开二度
Jake: Scored twice.
Jake:梅开三度
Jake: Scored three times.
Jake:帽子戏法了
Jake: Hat-trick.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Lucia:帽子戏法
Lucia: Hat-trick.
Lucia:不是加个小
Lucia: Not adding a little.
Lucia:不应该能
Lucia: Shouldn't be allowed.
其他人:别说了别说了
Others: Stop talking, stop talking.
Jake:哈哈哈炸死你
Jake: Hahaha, blow you up.
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:哈哈喷他去
Jake: Haha, go spray him.
Katrina: 往哪走
Katrina: Which way?
Katrina: 直走
Katrina: Straight ahead.
Shure: 往哪走来着
Shure: Which way was it?
Katrina: 直走吧
Katrina: Straight ahead, I think.
Jake:都行呵呵呵
Jake: Anything works, hehe.
Katrina: 都行
Katrina: Anything works.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehehehehehehehehe.
Jake:走走了造吧哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's get started, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈这话简直难以置信
Katrina: Haha, this is so unbelievable.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahaha
Jake:总能总能到吧
Jake: We'll make it, we'll make it.
Lucia:哈哈哈总能到吧
Lucia: Haha, we'll make it.
Jake:那边哎
Jake: Over there, hey.
Jake:回来了哈哈哈
Jake: Back again, haha.
Jake:不太行了
Jake: Not doing too well.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Pull back from the brink.
Lucia:那个50
Lucia: That fifty.
Shure: 这脑子呀
Shure: This brain, oh man.
Shure: 我天呐一天啥事都记不住
Shure: Oh my god, I can't remember anything all day.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 我就昨天应该加提醒时让再加个闹钟
Shure: I should've set another reminder alarm yesterday.
Katrina: 定闹钟我现在干啥事都定闹钟
Katrina: I set alarms for everything I do now.
Lucia:呃对是的
Lucia: Uh, yeah, exactly.
Shure: 哎呦喂真服了
Shure: Oh my, I really give up.
Shure: 哎我天呐
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 脑子呀脑子啊
Shure: My brain, oh my brain.
Katrina: 我的隐形眼镜终于可以
Katrina: Finally, I can wear my contacts.
Shure: 快长脑子吧
Shure: Please, brain, start working.
Katrina: 哎累了
Katrina: Ugh, I'm so tired.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 好香啊哇
Katrina: Smells so good, wow.
Lucia:好香啊
Lucia: Smells so good.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 我终于可以戴眼镜了
Katrina: Finally, I can wear glasses.
Jake:吃吃汉堡吃蛋挞
Jake: Let's eat, burgers and egg tarts.
Jake:吃什么呀
Jake: What should we eat?
Jake:蛋挞是吧
Jake: Egg tarts, right?
Jake:好有什么好的吗
Jake: Okay, anything good?
Jake:有有有好的甜品吗
Jake: Do we have any good desserts?
Shure: 我是一个巨无霸
Shure: I'm a big mac.
其他人:如果没有人点的就是我点的
Others: If no one ordered it, then I did.
其他人:但是我忘了你点的
Others: But I forgot what you ordered.
Katrina: 买成日抛了我操
Katrina: Bought the daily disposables, damn.
Jake:菠菠萝要
Jake: Pineapple, gotta have it.
Jake:可以要啊煎呗
Jake: Yeah, we can fry it up.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:吃吃吃吃
Jake: Eat, eat, eat
Jake:严谨严谨
Jake: Be meticulous, be meticulous
Jake:没关系盲盒麦当劳盲盒
Jake: It's okay, blind box, McDonald's blind box
Lucia:麦当劳盲盒
Lucia: McDonald's blind box
Jake:对麦当劳盲盒
Jake: Yes, McDonald's blind box
Jake:因为路就很远
Jake: Because the road is really far
Alice:走路去的吗
Alice: Did you walk there?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Alice:饮品在这里
Alice: The drinks are here